[Musik]
infineon valley ist man der meinung dass
man es dass es mit ein paar ethischen
feigenblätter angetan ist da wird zb die
liste auf gemacht dass diese systeme
natürlich datenschutzfreundlich sein
müssen und sicher sein müssen sie so ein
transparent sein und ganz wichtig ist
dass sie keinen bayers haben und dann
glaubt man dass es sich damit getan hat
das was ich unter digitaler ethik
verstehe das geht viel tiefer und da
fordere ich eigentlich die form aus auf
oder ab die vision dass sich junge wie
auch bestehende unternehmen
grundsätzlich gedanken machen welche
werte bringen sie eigentlich mit ihren
neuen technologien in die welt das sind
können ganz viele seine welche will man
davon auch tatsächlich in unseren
gesellschaften sehen und welche möchte
man in jedem fall schützen wo muss man
aufpassen und dieses grundsätzliche
nachdenken über das breite werte
spektrum was tangiert ist durch unsere
digitalen geschäftsmodelle und
technologien darum geht das allergrößte
problem bei der digitalisierung ist das
aufgrund des erheblichen datenvolumens
was anfällt wir sukzessive in den
letzten 20 jahren in einen überwachungs
kapitalismus reingerutscht sind an
letztlich kommen all diese coolen
freundlichen schönen services daher wie
eine schöne verfügung die aber letztlich
im nachgang ja uns überwacht und uns
unfrei macht uns kontrolliert und ins
uns im prinzip in eine stasi kultur
zurückwirft die wir dachten schon über
kommen zu haben und die sich nur einfach
besser anfühlen
das schöne ist dass es in den letzten
jahren viele junge kleine start-ups
gegeben hat schon die sich versucht
haben ethisch aufzustellen zum beispiel
datenschutzfreundliche services zu
schaffen und diese jungen unternehmen
zum beispiel statt what's up zu benutzen
kann man wunderbar streamer oder sydney
benutzen
man muss nicht google search benutzen
man kann
startpage benutzen man muss nicht google
maps benutzen man kann auch aogo
benutzen das sind
datenschutzfreundlicher dienste junge
unternehmen die auch dringend unsere
hilfe brauchen
weil sie nämlich nicht auf die
überwachung ihrer kunden und die
verlängerung unserer datensätzen waren
die tatsächlich versucht haben gute
produkte zu schaffen die auch ethisch
sauber sind und die konsumenten wir
kunden wir müssen jetzt diesen jungen
unternehmen helfen und wir müssen
umsteigen
wir müssen zwischen diese unternehmen
sind jetzt da die haben jetzt kapital
wenn wir nicht wechseln in den nächsten
jahren dann sind wir dann gehen die
pleite und dann sind wir eigentlich
diesen großen mono amerikanischen
monopolen auf absehbare zeit ausgelesen
tatsächlich hat das silicon valley eine
idee vom menschen eine sehr oft auch
sogenannte transnistrische sicht auf den
menschen die da sagt ja technologie die
wird jetzt benutzt um den menschen
möglichst relativ schnell zu upgraden
man muss doch erst mal ein tiefes
verständnis davon haben wer ein mensch
wer wir sind in unserem innersten was
uns auszeichnet
unsere intelligenz ist absolut nicht
verstanden keine künstliche intelligenz
ist in der lage auch nur annähernd die
form von intelligenz zu reproduzieren
die wir als menschen haben
wie kommt man dann im silicon valley
darauf dass man sich an mass dieses
unverstandene mit einer platten
digitalität einer zweidimensionalen 0 1
bit logik zu verändern
also ich bin ganz tief überzeugt dass
wir gerade in europa die möglichkeit
hätten uns über ehrliches value based
engineering im internationalen
wettbewerb zu differenzieren
wir können und wir haben auch das
technische know-how maschinen zu bauen
die einfach so viel besser sind als das
was wir heute haben
das bedeutet allerdings dass ist eine
qualitätsstrategie das ist keiner kostet
fischen sie block a strategy das
bedeutet dass man sich viel mehr
gedanken macht beim sogenannten
requirements engineering bei der
überlegung welche anforderungen stelle
ich an das system und das kostet ein
bisschen mehr
[Musik]